le gentleman cambrioleur est de retour
sur netflix pour une deuxième saison
cinq mois après avoir pulvérisé des
records et conquis des millions de
femmes partout sur la planète
lupin s'est classé numéro un dans une
dizaine de pays dont les états unis
mabut avec ses plus de 75 millions de
visionnements en 28 jours elle a même
dépassé la populaire série espagnole
casa del patel vous devez tenir votre
profession
la série non anglophones la plus
populaire sur netflix lol de france lui
pincer l'histoire d' assane diop
interprété par omar sy un admirateur
d'arsène lupin qui s'inspire de son
héros d'enfance pour venger la mort de
son père accusé à tort par un homme
riche et machiavélique pour qui ils
travaillent
outre le mélange action suspense et
comme le dit un des secrets du succès de
la série celle habile campagne
promotionnelle qui distille sur les
réseaux sociaux des indices et des aînés
par exemple à la fin de la bande annonce
de la nouvelle saison un lien
subtilement dissimulé nous guide vers le
site web qui confirme que la série
reviendra pour une troisième partie en
portant la bonne tenue au bon endroit au
bon moment
il est capable de se faire passer pour
n'importe qui n'importe où encore qu'en
mars italie coller des affiches dans le
métro pour prouver qu'il pouvait
vraiment passer incognito
la gentille
la première saison compte et seulement
cinq épisodes mais ça a suffi pour faire
exploser les ventes des livres en france
mais québec ou si j'avais beaucoup aimé
la première saison louis philippe est ce
que la deuxième saison est à la hauteur
des attentes
mon avis mes attentes et super élevé
parce que j'ai adoré la première saison
dans l'effet de surprise n'est plus du
tout là pour les cinq nouveaux épisodes
beaucoup plus hollywoodien et les
revirements certains sont absolument pas
crédible du tout métier de notre côté
c'est un plaisir coupable pourquoi je
dévorais et 5 vous étonne en deux
soirées ce projet de week end si la
dialectique la série télé privée du
canada à montréal
on est prêt à ça la magie